[music playing]
DANNY: When the local Fox 5 News
team asked us for some help,
we knew this was going to be
a totally different project.
It's not every day
you're asked to paint
cartoon foxes on a storm
chaser type of vehicle.
But my crew went
above and beyond.
And I got to tell
you, I couldn't
be happier with this vehicle.
Todd and Terri
from Fox 5 are here
today to take this storm chaser
vehicle back to the station.
And I just hope they are as
blown away over this thing
as I am.
So tell me now, you
brought us a 2005
Expedition, Ford Expedition.
And the object of the
game for this truck
is Fox 5 is going to
take it to schools?
Yes.
Well, we have a good
team meteorologist.
And they want to
go out to schools
and educate kids on whether.
I dig it.
So over at Fox 5,
you all have a mascot.
Rusty the Fox.
I understand you
really like Rusty.
The kids love Rusty.
Then you're really going to be
pleased with the look of this,
because Rusty is an integral
part of this vehicle.
- Oh, perfect.
- You ready for this?
- I'm ready.
- We're ready.
Come up here.
Let's wander up
in this direction.
I got two of my guys
bringing him out.
Yo, Ryan and Mike, bring out
that beautiful truck, man.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
That's incredible.
How cool is that?
That is incredible.
[engine revving]
DANNY: Feeling it?
Yeah.
DANNY: To get this baby
ready to tackle any storm,
we toughened her up by adding
cages to the headlights,
the tail lights, and a bright
LED light bar to the roof,
and some heavy duty
Nerf Bar running boards.
But the real story here,
man, is the paint job.
Ryan and his team hand-painted
every square inch of this truck
with Fox 5 mascot Rusty the
Fox, and all the weather
and landmarks of Las Vegas.
They topped it off
with a satin clear,
making it fingerprint proof so
it can handle a storm of kids
as well.
- That is awesome.
Look at this.
Well, there's
your Rusty the Fox.
He made it.
He's alive.
He's back.
The detail is incredible.
It's nothing what I expected.
It's meant to be interactive.
Every inch on this truck,
if you just keep looking,
you'll just keep discovering
more and more things.
And the idea behind
the satin clear on this
is it's kid hand friendly.
So by all means, have them
walk up, touch it, feel it.
And you're not
worried about, oh, kid
hands all over the shiny paint.
Yeah, there's a lot of
depth and dimension to it.
And there's even Mount
Charleston right here.
Yep.
Well, we said the
kids could touch it.
We didn't say you could.
The whole thing is all
literally hand-done artwork.
It's incredible.
We don't have a chopper,
but we have a balloon.
This is amazing.
It's fantastic.
Taking away from the paint
right now for just a moment,
we wanted to rugged
the truck up a bit.
So we stepped up the
wheel and tire package.
We went with these really cool
Cooper Discover AT3s on them.
They're an all-terrain tire.
They're an all-weather,
all-season tire.
They're great for
off road, and they're
also great on the highways.
So this truck can be rolling
down the highway all day long,
and then take it off on the
trails and things like that.
You've got the push bars, the
headlight protectors, the tail
light protects, all of that.
The truck drives
great, looks great.
It's got that tough vibe.
But then you look at what she's
saying, and every inch of her
tells a story that's going
to draw the kids right in.
And it's all the things
that happened in Vegas
that are weather related.
We have everything.
We've got snow.
We've got rain.
And that's where it
gets people interactive.
Who hasn't been in a
car wreck in the rain?
Who hasn't been
abducted by aliens out
in the middle of the desert.
That's right.
Did you go see the hood?
You guys got to
look at this one.
This is, in my opinion,
a show vehicle.
The artwork is
staggering all over it.
But the finish, man,
being able to touch it,
I don't ever touch our vehicles.
I just got to do that.
It will take the wind, the
rain, the sand, and the kids.
Yeah, we're done.
See you later.